I'm gonna tell you my story about
something that I did okay so so Roger
was invited to Dallas Texas to get a
drive-in movie award which was a hubcap
and this was in the nineteenth nineteen
maybe around 1980 anyway so Roger was
invited to get this award and word came
through the Secretary of the director of
the festival the drive-in Film Festival
in Dallas that shopping trips had been
planned for mrs. Corman now I think in a
previous time and this is why I say that
it it has to do with how the woman
reacts as much as how its society is so
that was a common way of society looking
at mrs. Corman right shopping trips but
by that time I think I had produced
about 10 or 12 films and I had a certain
amount of confidence and instead of
being offended or withdrawing or saying
oh thank you very much and going
shopping I said well that's very kind of
them but would you please send word back
from mrs. Corman that mrs. Corman is
more interested in co-production deals
well Dallas opened up with people who
were interested in co-production deals
and I ended up making two films there
the dirt bike kid and Ashley in getting
the financing in that direction from da
for da which I made in Ireland but with
film Dallas Pictures financing so I
think it's it's important to ask for
what you want because otherwise you're
not going to get it I like that is there
a certain way to ask for it well I don't
know that was the way it is that's what
happened so instead of being mad about
it it was just a very gracious you know
no thank you and then put out what you
didn't want I didn't say no I said more
interested in co-production deals than
shopping trips right
but thank you very much
you